In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading, from the Sinoxadion, from 9th, on which we commemorate, the Holy and
righteous Prophet Isaiah.
On 9th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Prophet Isaiah.
The Holy Prophet Isaiah was born in the kingdom of Judah in about 765 BC.
At a time when the Jewish people cruelly divided between the rival kingdoms of Israel, with
its capital in Samaria, and Judah, with Jerusalem as its capital, had just passed through
one of the most tragic periods in its history, concluding with the definitive destruction
of the kingdom of Samaria.
Isaiah exercised his ministry for 40 years, which were dominated by the increasing threat
that Assyria, the master of the East, was making to the Jewish kingdoms and their neighbors.
Caught in a vice between Assyria and Egypt, always tempted to rush into a two-frail alliance
with one of its enemies against the other, the kingdom of Judah was more and more corrupted
by the influence of foreign cults, by the moral perversion resulting from material prosperity,
and by the scorning of the law of God.
Magic, necromancy, and all sorts of superstitious practices replaced among the people the worship
prescribed by the law, and even those who remained faithful to the worship of the Lord in
the temple, contented themselves with a formalist and hypocritical religion, with their lips
they do honor me, but have removed their heart far from me.
In the year that King Uzziah died, 740, when Isaiah was in the temple, he saw the Lord in
all his glory, high on a throne and surrounded by six-winged Seraphim who cried, holy, holy,
holy is the Lord of hosts.
At the sound of these voices, the doorposts were shaken, and the temple was filled with
smoke, as in former times on Mount Sinai.
Falling to the ground, Isaiah confessed his unworthiness, saying,
Woe is me, for I am undone, because I am a man of unclean lips, and I dwell in the midst
of a people of unclean lips, from my eyes have seen the King the Lord of hosts.
One of the Seraphim was then sent to him, having a live coal in its hand that it had taken
with tongs from off the altar.
It touched his lips with it, and said, Lo, this hath touched thy lips, and thine iniquity
is taken away, and thy sin is purged.
He who was called the prophet with burning lips, offered to be sent to the people to proclaim
the will of God, in the hope of seeing them repent.
Shortly after this vision, he married, and gave his two sons names for telling by one
the trials to come, and by the other the remnant that must remain to become the seed of a new
people.
During the first years of his ministry, Isaiah began by preaching against the kingdom of
Samaria, denouncing its scandals and its false confidence in a complacent God.
Then, on returning to Jerusalem, where he remained for the rest of his life, he called on heaven
and earth to testify to the ingratitude of the people who had turned away from God to
give themselves to corruption and idolatry.
He proclaimed that the Lord would no longer endure their culpable hypocrisy, their sacrifices,
and their prayers.
Wash you, make you clean, cease to do evil, learn to do well, come now, and let us reason
together, though your sins be as scarlet, they shall be white as snow, but if you refuse
and rebel, ye shall be devoured with the sword.
The day of the Lord would then appear, which would cast down all that had been raised up,
and the loftiness of man shall be bowed down, and the hotness of men shall be made low, and
the Lord alone shall be exalted in that day.
These predictions of catastrophes were realized a very few years later.
When Razzan, king of Damascus, and Peca, king of Israel, wanted to force Ahaz, king of Judah,
into a coalition against Tiglath-Poliser III, king of Assyria.
When he refused, they attacked the kingdom of Judah, and Ahaz, instead of placing his
hope in God, turned to Assyria, in spite of Isaiah's warnings about the danger of such a policy.
While the people were preparing with great feverishness for the siege of Jerusalem, Isaiah
went before the king, who was overseeing the work, and said to him, take heed and be quiet.
There be faint-hearted, for the two tales of the smoking-fire-brands, for the fierce
anger of Razzan with Syria and of the son of Remalaya, thus saith the Lord God, it shall
not stand, neither shall it come to pass, and within three score and five years shall
afrem be broken, that it be not a people.
As Ahaz remained in credulous, Isaiah gave the clearest prophecy in the Old Testament
on the coming of the Messiah, the sign by which all men would be called to salvation.
The Lord Himself shall give you a sign.
Behold, a virgin shall conceive and bear a son, and shall call his name Emmanuel.
A little later, He made it clear that this child who would sit on the throne of David
would receive all power and bear the names, mighty God, angel of mighty counsel, everlasting
Father, Prince of Peace.
The prophet also proclaimed the ills that would soon descend on Damascus and Samaria.
In 733, Tglath-Paliza attacked Damascus, killed Razzan, and then ravaged Galilee, carrying
off the inhabitants.
The death of the King of Assyria in 727, occurring a little later, raised the King of Samaria's
hopes, and he attempted to revolt.
During the whole of this period, Isaiah unceasingly condemned this crazy policy, which was based
on a false hope in Egypt's support and which would lead to the condemnation of the Kingdom
of Israel to definitive ruin.
The crown of pride, the drunkards of Ephraim shall be trot in underfoot.
It would be thrown down by Azer, like the hailstorm that suddenly ravages the mulberry tree, and
the summer tempest that overturns houses.
In fact, after three years of siege, Hati Samaria was destroyed by the Assyrians, but Isaiah
proclaimed that after having served for a time as the instrument of God's wrath, Assyria
would finally be wiped out by Emanuel.
After the fall of the Northern Kingdom, the prophet withdrew from the scene until the beginning
of the reign of King Hezekiah.
Various of Israel's neighbors, nations under pressure from Egypt, then proposed to the Kingdom
of Judah that they should form a new coalition against the Assyrian oppressor.
Isaiah ran through the streets of Jerusalem for three years, barefoot, and having loosed
the sackcloth from off his loins to be the sign of an omen proclaiming that the vain hopes
of support from Egypt would bring nothing but ruin, exile, and destruction in their train.
This prediction was soon confirmed by the taking of Ashtad in Felistia, it, having counting
on Egyptian aid, also revolted against Assyria.
This ruination was followed by that of Moab, Edom, and Babylon.
On the death of Sargon II, King of Assyria, in 705, who was succeeded by his son Sinakarib,
many nations revolted on the initiative of the Philistines and the Phoenicians.
As a chia, though, despite his miraculous healing and the sign given by God, who, at Isaiah's
voice, had turned the shadow on the sundial back ten degrees, refused to place his trust
in God and joined the coalition.
He made siege preparations in Jerusalem, repaired the ramparts, doubled the fortifications, and
had an underground channel dug to bring food and water to the people.
An incorruptible defender of divine right, Isaiah came out of the shadows and censured the
Jews for making all these preparations, instead of weeping, mourning, and repenting.
He forcefully denounced the vain hopes that they continued to place in the chariots and
horses of Egypt.
This people that brought neither help nor profit, but only shame and confusion, and not in
the God of Israel.
He who had never gone back on his word and who overthrew like a torrent of fire, all the
arrogant powers of the world, and he pronounced this terrible sentence.
This iniquity shall not be purged from you till ye die.
Despite the prophet's efforts and remonstrances, the nations rose up, encountering crushing
repression from Sinakarib, who ravaging everything on his path wiped out Palestine's resistance
and laid siege to Jerusalem with a vast army in 701.
Hezekiah offered him all the gold, silver, and precious vessels that he had, emptying for
this his treasury and the temple, but the king of Assyria did not consider himself satisfied
and wanted the surrender of the capital.
The prophet Isaiah this time went to the king and the terrorized people no longer to threaten,
but to tell them that God would chastise the haughty assurance of the king of Azur and
would deliver his people as he had in former time delivered them from the Egyptians at the
Red Sea.
Azur would yield to the sword of divine justice and would become an object of derision
and contempt to the daughter of Zion.
That night the angel of the Lord killed 185,000 men in the Assyrian camp.
Sinakarib immediately abandoned the siege and returned to Nineveh where he was assassinated
in the temple of Nisraq.
Having fulfilled his mission, Isaiah once more became silent.
It is said that under King Manasseh who outdid all his predecessors in impiety and cruelty,
not sparing even the prophets who recalled the law of God to him, Isaiah was sawn in two
through the middle with a wooden saw on the king's orders.
In his testament, the prophet recalls that it was in conversion and calm that the people's
salvation would be found, but that having rejected it to put their trust in that which
is tortuous and disloyal, definitive ruin was prepared for them.
But for those who hoped in God, therefore will the Lord wait, that He may be gracious unto
you, and therefore will He be exalted that He may have mercy on you.
The book of the prophet Isaiah dominates all the other prophetic books in the Old Testament,
not only by the majestic beauty of its poetic expression, but above all by the accuracy
of its predictions concerning the coming of the Messiah.
It clearly proclaimed the virgin birth of him who, free of all sin, would be the hope
of his people.
This shoot from the stem of Jesse, that is of the house of David, would be anointed with
the fullness of the Holy Spirit, restored justice among men, and reestablished the peace
and harmony of paradise in the church.
But he who inaugurates the messionic age is also the humble servant of God.
He shall not cry nor lift up nor cause his voice to be heard in the streets.
A bruised read he shall not break, and the smoking flacks he shall not quench.
He will give himself willingly to a probrium for the salvation of his people.
He is despised and rejected of men, a man of sorrows.
I gave my back to the smiders and my cheeks to them that plucked off the hair.
I hid not my face from shame and spitting.
Surely he had borne our griefs and carried our sorrows.
He was wounded for our transgressions.
He was bruised for our iniquities.
The chastisement of our peace was upon him, and with his stripes, we are healed.
Delivered over to death like an innocent lamb led to slaughter, he will be placed in a
rich man's tomb.
But having this fulfilled the will of God and having offered his life in expiatory sacrifice,
he shall see the travail of his soul to show him light, and will reestablish Jerusalem
in his glory.
Although the prophet Isaiah pronounced numerous oracles concerning the imminent ruin of those
who put their trust in the powers of this world, thus throwing light on the final trials
through which mankind must pass in the last times, the second part of his book, that is called
the Book of Consolation, is almost entirely devoted to the proclamation of the reconciliation
of God with his people, of the renewal of Jerusalem, and the inauguration of a kingdom that has
no end.
A rise, shine, O Jerusalem, for the glory of the Lord is risen upon thee.
All nations will come to the church, the new Jerusalem, and will enter this city whose
gates will never again be closed, and will henceforth be lit neither by the sun nor
the moon, for the Lord himself will be their eternal light.
And all the righteous will belong to this people brought together by God.
He will rejoice in them, and they in him, and in this city death will be done away, and
there will be no crying, groaning, or lamentation, but only the praise of God.
Having thus proclaimed the good news, under a lightly veiled form, the Holy Prophet Isaiah
was rightly called the fifth evangelist, and his book remains one of the principal sources
of our faith and our hope.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.